welcome to this video play Grand Master
swatch from the Netherlands she's got
the name in them no but it's an older
handle don't know the Netherlands they
have so many so many strong stronger
players it's difficult to have an idea
what that is okay playing a pretty
pretty simple approach here taking on c4
play Bishop g4 typical sloth position
where Y term is the difference to the to
the normal Slav F not played a 4 which
means that I don't have so much
weaknesses on the queenside I'm a bit
too mystified ablex play here this
should be four and taking on c3 is quite
strange just giving me the bishop pair
with no particular compensation
and black needs to do something try to
get some counter play how do I keep the
center here trip to d3 and h3 maybe he's
got some play against the pawn here with
rook e8 may be coming if I play h3 takes
takes EDC denied p 6 steve force under
under attack
and rook e8 okay
the black is still fairly solid here G
for the ship to 69 h for this kind of
stuff they are probably at the ante will
take will take on d4 and or knee for
with some some technical tricks the
spinner sir is a big problem here maybe
I should move the Queen somewhere but
this always got this capture in 94 this
is so this is a real problem
I wanted to go Bishop T to hear but he
can take on f3 Queen takes ed find spin
on the pawn that's not good
I came ok so probably I must take with
the g point if he if it takes on f3
yeah not what I wanted but yeah I think
I maybe I missed time d for him the
position before that is certainly very
good for wide but he was probably not
well timed his counter player against my
center was very substantial
now King h2 looks more natural but you
might take plague winces 7 check
okq a queen III is very silly I can like
angle yeah
okay at least is taking some time and
what I want to do is maybe rook g5 and
sacrifice the exchange if he allows it
this could lead to an interesting
position okay now i have to ship c4 as
well Bishop c4 queen takes on c3 and
pull
I am taking far too much time here
totally nonsensical
don't want to take at the line morning
to put a piece on there for 22 look III
these kind of things should be ok the
most Queen h4 I have thanks to this
first if I get both both nights here I'm
okay
now this is ok really Queen takes f 4
but I want to protect this point first
as I have f4 anyway at age four anyway
check that's very good end game now yeah
this is a win for white I'm not
blundering anything check check check
black forfeits on time yeah I know mmm
how certain doom awesome that's let's
have a look at this the sole opening
play web Black is very questionable
giving up the bishop for absolutely
nothing but I made a mistake definitely
if Royce is bad I guess I mean at least
for a blitz game by a human player comp
still like why'd she likes why but I
should I shouldn't do that the poor nany
voice is getting after you find the bit
exposed I should probably play something
like this first activate this Bishop and
just keep the pawn structure as it is
it's probably better this was was now a
bit difficult to play for me it's got
this this pressure against you form and
what yeah he may be really G for him I
didn't I didn't like that very much but
the comp the computer certainty right it
points out that I could could have
played this mm yeah this could be good
for what 0.5 by the comprar at least
it's a little bit those this Bishop is
especially am questionable now yeah
maybe this is the key here I really
don't don't have anything actually I
think black should be better here now
computer is this gives black a slight
edge look back to be won by the comp
don't know
this is I spent so much time here it was
really useless maybe i'm okay still the
compass always on about equal c5 d5 I
don't know about I think this was now
definitely turning in whites favor quit
a for now I could yeah that's a good
move attacking a seven and d7 but I had
my side on this end game this is def
definitely definitely of quite good for
wide 0.7 or five or whatever switches
okay mm-hmm okay yeah after this I can
could've taken already yeah maybe maybe
this is also very nice because I get the
pawn and then I have a big porn role in
the center ads if probably even even
more convincing and I could have taken
here but I thought he has this move
which is of course not the case i can
sacrifice I this okay Queen f-4s then
really better yeah I could have I could
have won earlier really don't chat okay
here this is at least a a very
conveniently winning endgame always got
be 50 he's got be five I forgot to play
a four yeah I must definitely play for
you oops oops
while this this would have been awful b5
I just forgot about it now again a4
again you can play b5 he simply didn't
do that now I realize I should have play
that until my really winning Wow well
huh okay should be glad that he didn't
play that thanks for watching